bắt miếm có thông bây, tổng thống như đường nơi sẽ sết chặt thù mại với các nader sau khi ở tòa trên bố sẽ có giận nhất là Steve tại giải hỗn đồng để hợp báo tháng chí tới.
Cú thể viết trên trang mạng xa hội cả nhân trú xấu, ông trăm thế giữa sự ngờ bước về việc đặt đường một thảo thậu thậu mại với các nader khi nước này tuyên bố ủng hộ nhé,
nó Phalestine, đồng thời cạnh báo, nếu hai nước không đặt đường thảo thậu thậu thậu thậu thầy quan trước ngày 1,5 tháng 8,
Mỹ sẽ áp mức thời bàn mấy làm tình trăm với tất cả hàng hoàn các nader không thuộc khun khô về việc thông mại tự gió, bà nước Mỹ, Mexico và Canada.
Về việc ốc tàu a thủ tường các nader mắc khả nyi cho biết các cuộc đàn phản đối Washington mang tình xây dức,
nhưng nhiều khả năng không thể kế thuốc đúng hát, ông trò rằng sắc xuất Mỹ dự bỏ bảo bảo đủ thời hiện hành là rất thấp.
Các nader hiện là đối tác thương mại lượng thứ 2 của Mỹ sau Mỹ,
có đồng thời là khách hàng mua hàng hoàn Mỹ nhở nhất,
ông tàu a cũng là ngồi nguồn vật liệu khác và nhồn trình cho Washington và đang chữ các mức thời đối với hai mặt hàng này,
cũng bởi ổ tốt.
Cần đây thủ tường cơ tàu đào cho biết sẽ công nhận nhận nếu Phalestine tại khi họp đại ở đồng mếu quốc bỏ tháng chính,
Mỹ và Israine đã ngay lập tất liệt tiền phản đối đồng thái này.